at their heart cities are the absence of
physical space between people
cities are density proximity closeness
that proximity has plenty of upsides
like the ability to spread knowledge or
to facilitate trade but it also has
downsides like too much crime and too
much traffic congestion perhaps the most
important downside of urban density is
the spread of disease and for thousands
of years cities have been trying to
limit the awful costs of urban contagion
if you live in a city in the West
you probably view contagious disease as
an annoyance not a terrible
life-threatening scourge
we now have tools antibiotics vaccines
aqueducts that have so far worked pretty
well at preventing modern plagues the
one big exception was AIDS which caused
enormous damage to urban America during
the 1980s and 1990s and it still kills
abundantly in sub-saharan Africa if you
live in a wealthy country you're now far
more likely to die from cancer than
cholera but that wasn't true in the past
in 1900 a boy born in New York City was
still expected to live six years less
than a boy born in a countryside that
was about the same life expectancy gap
that existed in the time of
Shakespeare's London in this section we
explored the contagious diseases that
have often threatened cities why should
you care why every sip of urban water
doesn't carry the flavor of death as
AIDS reminds us disease could strike
again and we need to be ready to fight
back with the knowledge of how we fought
disease in the past you should also care
about urban health because many of the
developing world's cities remain
remarkably unhealthy and we're going to
explore how to reduce illness in those
places you should care about urban death
in Africa primarily because they're
people too but perhaps also because
plagues that begin in Africa might not
stay in Africa if we continue to treat
waterborne illness with antibiotics
rather than with better water systems we
may end up creating an antibiotic
resistant superbugs that could threaten
all of mankind finally the story of
urban health also matters because it
helps us to understand how cities can
work together to solve their own
problems the story of the fight against
cholera remains relevant for thinking
about the coalition's that could fight
high housing costs today or excessive
transportation congestion perhaps the
most important advantage of urban
proximity is that it enables us to work
together to make our world better
you